what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today is episode
6 of the pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as
usual we start by everyone introducing
themselves and where people can find you
hi i'm abby um you can find me on rave
culture
w-a-v-e-c-x-l-t-u-r-e on instagram
i'm 24 years old
and your relationship status single
hi i'm jessica and you can find me on
instagram at it's your girl jess it's
dot ya dot girl underscore jess and then
you can find me on youtube as well same
thing just without the
the
periods and underscores um and also
apostrophe and it's i am 27 and my
relationship status is single okay
that's new from last time i don't know
no no no no no
not here
it's live
okay guys um just see before we start i
forgot to do this i was supposed to do
this earlier our today's sponsor is
cooking with chris so he actually offers
completely customary meal meal plans i'm
sorry that you're good i was just
laughing completely custom meal plans
that allow you to eat delicious food
while being your healthiest self so if
you follow me on tik tok i've been doing
like updates on my meal plan and it's
been going good i'm down seven pounds in
two weeks okay and i'm getting more slim
and less thick so that's exciting okay
slim slim out here the link to that is
actually in the description and if you
guys buy one i get like
money from it pretty much which is going
to go towards equipment so i'm trying to
buy like three cameras so we can have a
bunch of different angles and i'm also
trying to buy another sound board so we
can have eight mics in here we have
eight people so
yeah consider doing that
so today's topic is what are the rules
of modern dating
so what to get so let's start with
have you guys ever been in a talking
phase
yes
yeah yeah i have two i think everyone at
some point has been in like a talking
phase and it's very can would you say
it's confusing or do you think that's
like natural like i think that's how it
should go
how is it it should be confusing
oh should there be a talking phase oh
[Music]
yes but i don't think it should be
too long i don't think you should be in
the talking stage for
a year and be like well then
yeah well no i think it's too long
but um
what was your other question you asked
do you
um i just asked if you think there
should be a talking phase because it
used to be like reporting like it used
to be very traditional
and now like the more modern version of
courting is like talking
yeah so i think there should be a
talking phase but i don't think it
should last
long
okay what about you i feel like talking
is like the dating phase for example
like then what's the point of it
yeah talking if you're dating but who
really invented the word talking like i
feel like you know like i've done this
so like
but as you get older you start dating
and you can date a few people dating
doesn't mean necessarily you're dating
exclusively you're just dating a few
people that's how you find out what you
like you go out on dates you get to know
someone
and i feel like it's like that but i
think it's kind of
less
standard i feel like i'm being rude now
but less standard in terms of you're not
obliged to go out on dates you're just
kind of talking over a messaging app or
maybe on the phone or facetime
and then then you get into relationship
but it's the same for me it's the same
thing as
it's most less but it's like dating like
you go on a few dates with someone
you're getting to know them and then you
decide is this someone i want to be with
can you see yourself with them
yeah i don't know i have a question
is talking different in the uk than the
us i can't even answer that maybe you
can what do you mean what do you mean
i'm not in the u.s no in the uk
like what what is talking to you
like yo you're like talking like you're
messaging and like you're doing phone
you're doing phone calls with someone
okay like you're talking to them and
do you want to getting to know phase i
think and then you like you build like
that emotional and
physical and like connection with that
when i hear talking i don't know if this
is the same for you when i hear talking
i think hooking up that's why yeah under
the context of a relationship is that
what you think of um
not necessarily um when i think of
talking it's just like getting to know
someone
now when i think of dating i'm like oh
i'm dating this person like that's my
boyfriend we're together that's what i
think of dating but when i um moved it
from where i grew up to where i am now
dating is you're going out on dates with
somebody and then you have a boyfriend
and girlfriend so there was like an
extra step in between it was just
oh that's interesting
that is what what about
so you think dating is like
like you're not exclusive if you're
dating yeah i think you can you can like
you can day i think in like the dating
world like
um
as you get older as well so i was like
young adults or adults
you do date like you're on a dating
phase like you go on multiple dates with
different people like you're not
actually unless you've obviously got if
then you get to the point where you're
then exclusive with one person and
that's the agreement you come with so
it's their prerogative but yeah i think
you can like you can date multiple i
don't think dating means
that's my boyfriend that's for me like
oh i'm in a relationship with you i
wouldn't class that that's not the
terminology i would use so another
question okay this has been kind of
because i guys i'm gonna i'm gonna give
credit where credit is due kevin samuels
inspired this topic i know i know he
talked about this oh boy so he talks
about how it's like really confusing for
guys because
they
they want to know when they're gonna get
laid basically
and do you think there should be a
certain amount of dates like do you
think that's something you should tell a
guy up front like we go on this amount
of dates then before we sleep
together because i don't think i could
do that have you ever seen like a man
what have you think like a man but megan
good to know
yeah have you watched it yeah so she
what was it the nine is it nine or three
dates oh no 90 day ball she had a 90 day
walk okay and she was like so she's not
like i think on the third day she said
i'll invite you for a night cap nightcap
didn't mean we're gonna hook up or
anything but she was like it's a 90 day
ball and then we can sleep together okay
so for 90 days they went dating
and then they
did the deed and slept together
basically and yeah that was already
so a lot of times in like the sector of
youtube they'll say if a girl's making
you do that she's not really that
attracted to you because there are guys
that she would like do that with right
away it's just not you do you think
that's good or bad advice
i think that's bad advice because there
might be some women out there who
actually want to get to know somebody
and not have the physical be
incorporated in that and so like 90 days
gives them that chance to know
oh okay i like actually being around
this person instead of just being like
oh no i just like doing the deed with
this person
so
yeah i think i think that they're
well i think that that's bad advice see
i get i get mixed okay
because on one hand
i know it takes me a while to feel like
comfortable with somebody yeah so i
think there would be guys that i would
be really cause i think of me right when
people say advice and i'm like no there
would be guys that i'm actually into but
i just like
i don't know i'm
i'm awkward like
no i feel you
i can't but at the same time i also know
girls that will make one guy like do all
these dates do all this stuff while
she's hooking up with the guy she
actually wants
interesting i've seen that have you
i may have like heard of it like
um
[Music]
heard of having like a person for this a
person while you're like you're still in
a relationship they call it uh
steak daddy's a wife still in a
relationship yeah a steak daddy so you
have like
flavors
yeah it's take that he's an autistic
steak like food state
a steak daddy is
um someone who can buy you food and then
you have someone who can
uh take you uh here shopping
oh yeah london is expensive um it is
gonna be my steak daddy
steak daddy i mean if she got it like
that
so yeah that's what that's what the
young whipper snappers call it steak
daddy so but like a lot of times i hear
because a lot of this space is like
men's advice so i'll hear their advice
and i'll understand where they're coming
from but then part of me is like well
that wouldn't work on me yeah exactly
but then guys get
sort of like annoyed because they're
like i guess every girl says that
they're different
[Laughter]
unfortunately but we are we are all
different
[Applause]
he says stop the cap okay have you ever
tried to make someone jealous
no
no it's just happened
yes it's just happened i've never
intentionally gone out my way like i'm
gonna try and make you jealous i feel
like yeah but if it just happens because
i'm not big on the jealousy thing yeah
no why you just no i haven't
no i've never tried to make someone
jealous but someone's tried to make me
jealous and it worked really yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was more just like
i was kind of
not sure about if i like him or not does
that make sense so
he invited me to like hang out with him
okay and then basically i saw him on
social media like interacting with
another girl
um it wasn't like anything crazy just
like flirting and it kind of made me be
like
like no i want him yeah
okay so it kind of made me a little more
like aggressive i guess with it because
i i didn't want to
i did i it's kind of like when you see
he has another option yeah you it makes
you it sounds so bad but it kind of is
but like it makes you like want it more
yeah i think that's a natural thing
though like i'm like that like i like i
don't like it like too easy
but then a bit of like a challenge or
competition i'm like oh like don't you
want a guy that you feel like you earned
almost a little bit yeah i like i like a
little bit of a chase i don't know if
that's is that toxic
is that toxic of me
i think it's i don't know i think it's
toxic to me too
like i would should we work on that
let's walk back let's
just work on that
i've always been like that like my
friends do tell me about it um
yeah i think it's i think it's a good
thing because it's like like maybe like
with work and stuff like you're black i
really want to earn that and earn that
career and that job position
but i think
i think sometimes maybe it's not toxic
but maybe we maybe sometimes we go back
the wrong way
if that makes sense it does yeah because
it's on one hand you think wow that's
super like jealous so that's not that's
like bad that he did that right but on
the other hand i'm like well it worked
it's attractive yeah like i went on to
date that guy
it's like you can't you can't get mad at
it hate the player
so it's kind of like
so i are there any games like what games
have you guys heard of in dating or done
yourself
anything hold on talk keep
i'm trying to think i don't think i
really played you know i'm not really
playing games but i'll be like so i'm
like okay this is what i want but then
there's times i think if i'm not sure
what you want i'll be like let me gauge
what you want yeah but i don't know if
there's like a game i played i think
it's like i'll see if you hit maybe hit
me up or if you try a bit
so it's not like i'm just
i'm chasing you because i like a chase
but then i don't like i don't like
chasing you too much to the point
i'm like a fan basically yeah
do you know what i mean because i'm
really like who am i i'm not a fan
no
it's a privilege to have me like you
yeah so yeah i don't know do you play
games i don't know what about you paul i
mean have you ever haven't you ever
wanted to respond slower so you don't
seem too desperate i've done that i
considered it
kind of because you're not
you're tactically thinking that that's
yeah
yeah i've done that multiple times to
where i'll get a text and sometimes i'm
like
chill out like slow down give it some
time
and then i'll be like i'll give it like
five ten minutes and then i'll see i'll
see how long it took them to text me
back and i'll wait that time and then
some
but guys what if they're like really
busy because you know i'm the worst i
can't play games like if i see the
message
like my phone do not disturb a lot of
the time so but if i go on them like if
i see this notification i would just
open it and that's just me because it's
like then i'll just forget about and
i'll probably reply like three days
later which is really bad but then do
you guys analyze when they reply and you
think oh
why have you applied like five hours
later but if there was like really busy
had a really busy day do you take that
as a sign of not not not interested or
do you do you ever consider the fact
that or the possibility that maybe
they're busy because i feel like that's
happened to me in reverse like i've had
guys like sometimes i'm just busy and i
just don't have time to really dedicate
the energy i can give to you in that
message so i'll wait i also feel like if
i really like the guy i'm not busy ever
okay unless i'm
i mean if i'm doing a show right yeah
clearly so like for example now yeah now
like i'm not going to be texting someone
now or if you really like them would you
not like say if you saw and maybe you
had like the one second say you had like
20 seconds to really reply to that and
your phone was right there would you
really not go for that message would you
wait and be like you know i actually am
busy i'll reply to you after like do you
ever make that conscious decision um
not
if i really like the guy i usually just
respond but
but here's the issue though the older i
get the less had i put it like i just
don't like but my pride used to get in
the way a lot more when i was younger
but i would just find myself like
wasting my time yeah and so i just kind
of try to do a lot of interest now and
see if they reciprocate and if they
don't i just keep going yeah
when i was younger i was much more like
how long until he was about like you
know what i mean like stuff like that
it's almost a little immature yeah um
as for me
when i was younger i would i would do
that but
try to respond quickly and see how long
it took them to reply but i always i
always gave people like the benefit of
the doubt like oh
if you may be doing something you didn't
text me back and then if i found out
that if you weren't doing anything i'd
be like okay cool i'm not about to lose
no sleep over it and so as i've gotten
older it's been like just more like oh
either i'll talk to this person or i
won't i'm not about to lose sleep over
a person either they are interested in
communicating with me or not
if you're okay if you're single single
like not not sleeping
not sleeping with anyone or anything
okay yeah
how many guys do you talk to at the same
time and what i mean is talking to you
as in
not not someone you just matched without
an app like one or two but like like
talking to when you're interested in
so i'm curious if we're gonna have the
same number
how many
you wanna look in your phone
because you're single single yeah
um
let me think
at first i was like i've never done that
then i thought and i said
let me retract that and think
i think the most i've done and probably
the most i can mentally take
is
two
i get that i can mentally
this is if i'm not like hooking up or
spending a lot of time with anyone yeah
this is a single single yeah this is
like so what's the quantity
so but you said right now you said it
i actually hit the number
um
i'm trying to think so
oh no what if they see this
pearls like i got this one this one this
one this
one um
maybe like no it's not that many i was
just thinking like who i would count and
who i wouldn't count mm-hmm
how would they separate yeah
well i would think like guys that i'm
actually interested in like that i
cuz i don't when i was younger i might
have entertained like guys that i like
you know but like the older you get you
just get less time yeah and less
tolerance yeah yeah um
because i'm trying to think like guys
i'm actually interested in maybe three
or four i would say okay but that's i'm
not really like consistently hanging out
with any of them okay is it just like
more messaging it's just more like
messaging talking on the phone does that
make sense yeah how many of those would
you actually like go on dates with all
of them all of them yeah okay
like different area codes
okay
okay but
yeah i would say five i can like
maintain but you also only have so much
time mm-hmm so yeah yeah what about you
what's your i would
if it was
just
having them just to like talk to them
and not have an interest
i wouldn't i probably wouldn't have a
lot
i'm trying to think
has has happened
oh you got to think about it
i think the most has been three
okay
and then
if i'm interested in someone the most i
can do is to like just like having like
one over here that i talk to one over
here that's the most right i can do
you're actually
if i'm hanging out with someone and like
they're like like then i only have one
yeah but i can't i can't hang out with
more than one guy at the same time it's
too much
it's kind of like i'll go on a date or
two with a guy
and if i like him then i'll kind of just
start to drop at like everyone else yep
same and then
if i
if i don't then i just end it and i'm
like oh no i'm on to that you know same
what about you
is it different in britain
uh
i wouldn't i don't know because you know
i have no idea what it's like to date in
another country so i i don't even know
how to answer that question yeah that'll
be so wrong with me but
i feel like i can
if we're saying talking
maybe when i was younger i could talk to
like more guys i'd be talking like six
yeah seven guys because you're just
messaging like i'm just i'm literally
replying yeah but it's like the way the
certain energy i would give to a lot of
them is so different depending on my
interest in those people like like you
said like
you know the guy might be interested in
me and i'm just entertaining it and
that's what i used to do is when i was
younger yeah like i just did not care
about the guy's feelings whereas now i'm
like more very unconscious so for me
personally i
yeah i could go and i could go on i
could date different people and then
narrow it down like like you said if
you're interested in
someone like you kind of cut off the
others type not cut off but like you
know like you wouldn't hang as much with
the other people which is what i would
do so maybe like now
i think maybe like two people i don't
know about three
only because it's like the energy the
time i'm so busy like my mind's
elsewhere like yeah for me it was just
like if i'm not like interested that's
where the snake daddy would come into
play i can't even fake the energy now
it's too much
now i can't either
well i don't
like
because right now i'm not um
really like hanging out with any of
these guys so it's like but i feel like
i could only hang out with one or two at
a time yeah
yeah i just don't know
but in college
it's a little different oh jesus college
because everyone's close
so you can like you can hang out with
people so much quicker because
everyone's right there convenience yeah
i get that maybe 40 acres
really it was so small you could just
oh first that makes sense
yeah because i understand convenient
like being at uni
like we live on campus as well yeah flat
convenience is such a big thing
to the point maybe even make poor
decisions because convenience and it's
like
but yeah i do get that because it's just
so much easier compared to if you like
say you live like 40 minutes away or
something and then actually making the
effort to go
and see another video yeah it's
different like you really wouldn't wait
okay question have you ever dated a guy
that was in the friend zone
let me start with my first question do
you believe guys and girls can be like
platonic friends
yes yes oh really i do yeah oh my gosh i
so
do you have a guy best friend guy friend
yeah
yes yes so if you called him and said
i'm horny oh god i wanna [ __ ]
no
do you think what do you think he would
say yeah
so then how is he for you
no no do you know i have a friend um
that i think
we
we had we kind of flirted here and there
okay but it was never that like
i think we knew that i think it was just
we both when we met like we was just it
was like crazy times in our lives
i think yeah like now like like i think
we crushed on each other at one point
and then i think we actually came to a
conclusion like yeah we're actually so
great as friends that we talk about
about other our other situations guys or
girls like our dating life you're still
attracted to each other yeah no no no no
no no so if you call him
but i call him yeah calm down tell him
i'm
like abby what the hell
but yeah like now i think if you if you
call them and said that i'm horny yeah
and say like look it's just a one-time
thing oh my god and then you said you
made it like think you were serious you
can't be joking okay because first he's
gonna say like try to see if you're
serious yeah yeah he'll i think he knows
me so much the point he'll know i'm like
not serious yeah because he knows
because we've spoken about it
like so much to the point i think he
knows like this is never going to happen
okay no i've been in i i actually do
think that i think men and women can be
friends but i think it's rare
i think most of the time it's it's
um
there's some kind of backstory too
i think i think if if they are friends
it's usually because they lived by each
other maybe grew up together or in the
same friend group yeah then you can have
a friend like that yeah
but
i don't know i think a lot of times
because i've had guys make it out of the
friend zone have you
in in my life yeah no like i've had
those
i turned down at first and then i liked
them later no no no yeah i think i know
if i'm going to like them or not yeah i
also think do you know i agree with you
so like
so for example like
i feel like this is such a deep
conversation sorry so i feel like men
and women they're not actually made to
be friends i feel like that's something
that we created as humans i feel like
right like we're actually put on this
planet like men and women organically to
be attracted to each other yeah to
reproduce that's the main purpose yeah
so i think it's actually so natural for
a boy like a man and a woman to be so to
be attracted to each other and
pursue something there like it's not out
of question do you know what i mean yeah
so i think it's normal i think the fact
that men and women are friends is
something we took to a whole another
extent you know why does that make sense
so i i think it's kind of not normal but
it is the normal like when how we were
created no yeah if that makes sense no
it does
yeah i don't
i don't think it's natural really i
don't think men and women are naturally
meant to be friends yeah no so i agree
with that yeah but i think it's
like man-made i agree yeah i think we
created that it's like even like i think
it's evolution like even like with the
whole lgbt like um a lot of people being
like like part of the lgbtq btq
community i think that's something that
comes with evolution
like organically like obviously like if
you take it like real back yeah like men
and women are made to just really
reproduce it's not animals you know how
animals like yeah the cats they may and
they just make kids and that's it that's
their purpose i feel like that's kind of
ours like women that's why women are
gifted with the
organs
not even men because that's what it's
for yeah just to recreate
so okay i have another question
do you think so this is a modern like
dating question a little a little off
topic but
do you think it's deceptive that women
get work done
and use filters
like do you think it's deceptive if a
woman gets a bbl and she doesn't tell
the guy
oh
yes i'm just gonna say yes
i i do
um
because essentially
that's not that's not what you look like
and
if you i'll say if you plan on having
kids it's kind of deceptive because your
husband may think oh my um my kids are
going to have like strong legs
like strong just be strong and like
naturally that's not
what
um comes from the woman's side because
she doesn't have it and
i think in that area it's deceptive
because of just the reproduction of the
kids
but on the other hand if you don't plan
on having kids and
the man really doesn't
care what you look like just as long as
you look the same 24 7.
it's not deceptive can i ask you
something yes so
with regards to that at what point do
you so is it they have to be your
boyfriend
for you to tell them that or is it maybe
when you start talking or dating them
you tell like do you tell them in the
first instance so they know from the
get-go like do you know what this is
what you've got done like how does it
like explain that
if that makes sense
no it does um
it would
i don't know because it would all
depends on if the person wants to
disclose that do you know what
yeah no no i understand what you're
asking it's just if the
the person
wants to disclose that or if they feel
that it's something that they need to
let them know it'd be a upfront thing
like hey like i don't look like this
naturally this is what i look like when
i was born to set in the third or they
just says like this is me now this is
how i see myself in my head and i
finally seen it on the outside so it all
depends on if they want to disclose it
i'm actually glad you gave the first
thoughts you gave because you know i
never ever saw it like that like in
initially i think
why does everyone really have to tell
them because that's still them but then
i think the fact that you said do you
know what maybe the maybe their partner
might think wow my kid's gonna have a
great body or great arms or great legs
and that's really because of
plastic surgery yeah
um
but then i also just thought i was
thinking about in other terms like you
know when it comes to like fake stuff so
for example like say we get our hair
done yeah like are we gonna do it like
say a guy might be like long straight
hair
like down to my ass it's all healthy
it's amazing yeah like is he gonna is
that something i have to disclose in the
first instance because he's gonna think
oh wow like is my kids gonna have great
great bloody hair or something like that
like that's what i was thinking about
what you said like at what point do you
disclose it to them because
maybe i don't need to tell you when you
first meet me and maybe approach me and
go like what's your name i think maybe
you know i mean i guess yeah
yeah like when you're
because is it their right to know
if it was me i would say boyfriend and
girlfriend yeah because i don't think in
the talking stage you really need to
tell that to someone but when you're
getting to like the point where you
could get married and be a little more
serious even with the like the plastic
surgery as well like saving like face
stuff
i think it's going to be hard to
because some some people get um
work done now it's quite naturally it's
quite natural like say like for some
people it's more extensive but say it
was quite natural like say i had work
done you wouldn't even know like say
it's all done um is that something maybe
you think i should tell you in the talk
like dating stage because
imagine you get into a relationship with
me and then you find out and say that's
something you really don't like
like is that not kind of a disrespect as
well i don't know boyfriend and
girlfriend you should that's what i
would say because is it their business
that's another thing it's quite personal
isn't it but i i think if a guy's
willing if you guys are a serious
boyfriend and girlfriend you're working
towards marriage right because when when
i'm trying to get like i'm trying to get
a ring
by spring you know
this finger is a little light
i need some 30 cabinet on this [ __ ]
so
i if if i if i was having a guy that
wants to spend the rest of his life with
me
i think that's something he should know
before we get married okay yeah
does that make sense yeah i know i i am
because that's such a big commitment i
think they deserve to know
now this brings up another question oh
go ahead so back in the old days okay
old days i don't know maybe like before
birthday how far back okay before birth
control i think it was developed in the
60s
because you know you had the consequence
of getting knocked up yeah now the
average age of first marriage is uh like
27 28 i think it's 31 late 20s yeah 27
28 yeah i think it's i think it's 31 in
the uk actually okay but in the us it's
no i think girls it's 28 29 it's getting
higher yeah men is one or two years high
higher yeah woman is younger um
that's a lot so now we got like a decade
of dating
do you think that
women and men should disclose their past
pasts to each other
as in like past relationships or just
past everything like if a guy if a guy
says hey i want to marry you but i just
want to know how many people have you
slept with or something like that
like do you think that's their
information to know
they have every right to ask i feel like
i think when you come together you are
one i think it's good to know things
because maybe it's better you like
personally
i would like to have a com like i think
before even the marriage i would like to
have a conversation with my partner
about their past i think it's t for me
to even get to know them better and
understand who they are as a person and
just just so i find things out from them
mm-hmm rather than other people i think
we live in a world where
social media yeah yeah everyone knows
everyone let's be real like there's a
whole community like different
communities like we all have mutuals i'm
going to find out you're going to find
out i think but i think there's also
obviously the level of respect where
that is if someone wishes to not
disclose that that's their prerogative
and whether you just accept that that's
a whole nother like thing but yeah
that's actually a good way to put it
because it's kind of like i think
everyone has the right to ask yeah you
kind of have to do what you want with
that information yeah it's how it's what
you do like you said like what you do
with that information so if you want
like if he wants to accept that like
you're never gonna know yeah and if i
wish to not disclose that whether you
accept that that's your prerogative yeah
that's it just depends on the person
isn't it i've never like lied about any
of that stuff i've always i've always
been like very very i think i'm too
honest yeah i think i'm i think
same because it always messes me up
because
it's interesting because in like this is
they call it the red pill sector of
youtube okay their advice to women is no
any number any number above one is too
many
not just because
a guy
like
he wants to know but he doesn't yeah and
you would get better outcomes as a woman
if they just don't know because no
number is going to be like right wow but
do you think that's what they say i'm
not saying that's what i agree with is
that if the men asked and then the woman
says i'm not going to tell you oh
they're actually they tell you to lie in
the manual sphere that's a donovan but
the men always say what do they say
times it by three or two when the girl
when a woman told or girl tells you
their body counts yes what do you count
times or like after
like
i hate that genevic
what's the name of your life i'm like
what because i actually be telling the
truth
i tell the truth should i divide it by
three yeah exactly i don't think it's
their business to know how many people
you slept with um i think if they want
to know your past and who you've
seriously been with i don't think it's
that like i think we're at a day and age
where we just have to accept like okay
like women or men like vice versa have
stepped with people and it's not being a
serious relationship how they're however
they want to cross it okay but this is
this is what i think of okay devil's
advocate right yeah dude's marrying a
girl right yeah what if he finds out
later that
okay we could even talk about only fans
she used to have an only fans yeah or
she used to you know she slept with the
whole basketball team in college
like that's gonna that's i i think he
would be kind of salty you know i don't
blame him yeah that's what i would say i
don't know this is provocative yeah who
are we to question that so it's kind of
like i don't want to go that far
i wouldn't be if like the roles were
flipped and there was a dude i was about
to marry and he was like yeah back in
college i did this this and this i just
have only fans blah blah
if it has nothing to do with
our relationship and it doesn't affect
us negatively it doesn't put us in any
harm
i would just be like okay that's your
past like you
ran through the basketball team and had
only fans cool and you had fun but
here's but here's the problem though
because you don't have that like like
remember like men have the biological
imperative to be disgusted by you
sleeping with other men yeah the
standards that we're held to it's not
the standards it's like biology so like
historically they had to ensure
paternity so a woman that slept around
they had to ensure that that was their
kid and they would be donating like
resources it's not really their fault
the same way it's not our fault we like
tall successful men because we wanted a
guy that would take care of us
historically like there's still the
biology is still instilled in us i'm not
saying it's it's realistic in this day
and age like we're getting married at 27
to like 30 yeah sometimes even older
yeah yeah so i'm saying like
it might not be you know
useful but
like the biology is still there yeah
oh my gosh i i could not date a guy if
he used to have an only fans i thought
it would be no no that would be no i i
hate that because that's your poker tip
it all depends on what the only fans is
if it's a little racy one i've been if
you made like if you made some money
like
boy go ahead and make your own yeah
like that's how i feel like i don't
think your past is something for me to
judge and vice versa but i completely
respect if i end up with a guy that is
disgusted by that because that's really
your preference and yeah why should you
not be entitled to want what you want
that's what i always say do you know
what i mean i would never ever be mad
about that like yeah want what you want
but what can you get
like you should hold yourself like why
settle if this is the standard you want
that's what you like hold yourself up to
like probably we've even spoken about
obviously your parents and yeah what
they came from so maybe you even hold
your self to like a standard man that
you want because you see that in your
dad for sure what you've been around and
that's what a lot of comes like comes
from and yeah why can't you like if
that's what you're around and your dad
said that's that highest the highest
standard for you and your mom it's like
right do you know what i mean i heard
anyone tell you but here's here's the
problem what can i get
so what can you find
yeah
i'm saying like like on one hand you
know if i i think if i wait around for a
guy that's you know
a multi like i mean my dad wasn't rich
when they started dating yeah but like
i think sometimes
that's good advice to keep your
standards high but sometimes it keeps
girls single
because
[Music]
because it's like what can you get
imagine you end up really happy at 40.
like look at gabrielle union she found
the love of her life how old is she like
40 she's 40 something
i think maybe even mid-40s do you think
rihanna stayed single for she's 28 29
pregnant she's like 33. she's 33. okay
she's like she's only now she's been
tickled for so long she's been in like
toxic relationships have relationships
been all over like worldwide her the
chris brown situation yeah all of those
dilemmas
like
imagine you actually hold yourself like
you hold it down stick to your standard
yeah now look at her and asap rocky like
that's cute
gabrielle union
[Music]
her partner
dwayne wade yeah dwayne like
how old is she she's 40 something she's
i think 10 years nearly 10 years younger
than her i'm
not that that's what i want but i'm just
like
theoretically do you think that's like
the exception rather than the rule
because these are celebrities that have
a bunch of money to like put into their
appearance yeah you know like i get that
i don't know
i think if you tell most people to wait
till 40 that's like bad advice it is
most people geriatric pregnancy is
expensive yeah you got 40 grand to put
down
at that point i wouldn't have no kids
imagine you really commit say be like
okay i got what you mean so say i
actually maybe brought my sanders down a
little i think there's always an
exception even with your standards as
well like we will always have this
standard but when we really go for a guy
we let a lot of things slide that's what
we actually do
that is what donovan
the he's a guy i work with on youtube
yeah
and i was saying how i didn't want to
date a guy with a kid right yeah i was
like um like i
i've been in that
no no kids no children yeah good on the
kids and he said okay who's your
celebrity crush and i said this man his
name's zooby you probably don't know who
he is i do you know who's here and he's
gone on he he was on um the rap game i
am in love with him like respectfully
like an enormous
game he's like he came on as a guest
i think he's so fine
he cooks
no he's not i don't know he's a like a
political commentator and like rapper
okay i think he might be he's british so
you might know who he is yeah
but
um
i don't know i i think he's so cute but
if he said okay what if zooby had a kid
and i was like
of course
i was like oh god that'd be really hard
to say no to but i really like i i know
i should say no but it's like you give
someone the benefit of the doubt and
kind of overlook things when you really
really like them yeah i think standards
are a guideline
i don't think it's necessarily something
maybe you can
always live up to in every aspect like i
feel like our standards are so
unrealistic like we like we can say we
don't want a man that lies your mind
could lie to you about like one little
thing are you really going to dump him
do you know what i mean like i think
it's more guidelines and you kind of you
have to compromise on each thing and
that's just life
it's not anything like even a job like
you just have to
find a way to compromise but keep both
of you happy and you give what you want
to give and do you know what i mean
yours are crazy so they asked the men
and women they said you go on a date
with someone
and that person has 80 of what you look
for so whatever your list is okay okay
and they said would you go on a second
date
most men said yes most women said no
really yeah eighty percent
pretty good though am i wrong
no she said most women would say no
to going on a second date but i think
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm like
eighty percent i'll go to the second day
what do they want
nine percent like
wow
yeah so what's your what's your do you
have a list of things you look for
i used to when i was younger i used to
have a full-on list and then i got a
list i did like really i wrote out a
list um but then as i got older it's not
that i lowered my standards it was just
like i
don't want to be so focused on the list
to list the list that i don't
let life happen yeah so there are like
specific things
like just minor things that i need on my
list but other than that i don't have
like oh you don't do that you don't make
this and by no it's not that so what
i mean you have to have some like yes
have a certain height requirement oh
yeah like the
the physical ones
yes those are like a requirement good
could you date a guy shorter than you
have you
he's hot
no i couldn't
i couldn't
i don't want to answer this no it's okay
[Music]
i'm always gonna
i just think about my wedding
i love night talking
i love going out and getting dressed up
like hills and just the whole look i'm
just so into it and it's like
no i can't
i can't
oh my gosh yeah i couldn't no no no
that's shallow with me then no it's okay
i mean
guys are shallow like people have
shallow requirements like dating is
they'll try to shame you on the internet
for it but i will not i will not be
ashamed i wouldn't know for wanting what
i want come on because that guys will
want so is it shallow then for them to
want a woman that's what a virgin
do you know what i mean it's the same
thing like
no
yeah no one could say me i think the
difference though is men are more
willing to like settle
and women aren't
because men
like for example what do you think the
average again these are u.s stats like
the average weight of a girl in the is
average i would say one height weight
145 155. five five wow so it's like
overweight
wow
really
and so but you know someone's dating
them and sleeping with them yeah where
the
i don't i don't think most girls would
like sleep with a guy that's making like
45 000 a year if he wasn't hot
this that's the sad thing about it um
it's just so
i don't know why that is
that
it's
like that
but it i feel like sometimes it cuts out
like
people having the opportunity to
actually like connect with somebody
instead of having
this like listless list and initially
you
meet that person you're like you don't
check this major box so i'm not even
going to like pursue anything with you
when it's like you never knew if they
checked all the other boxes yeah no i
agree yeah i agree that's like
definitely been a problem for me because
i have i don't have a long list i have
like five things i look for but i would
always if a guy didn't have every single
one of those five things it'd just be a
no
[Music]
like for example um
like in shape okay i wouldn't have dated
my last boyfriend if i had like that as
like a heart yeah
like a non-negotiable yeah because he
was like slightly overweight but you
make a girl laugh
he's actually very fit now
i said he's actually very fit now
so maybe you spoke something into them
they always blow up off though yeah
oh no that was
yeah i did yeah
i don't want to talk about it
for moving
i'm trying on see what other questions
i'll look at the chat guys if you want
us to read if you have any questions for
us put them in the chat um send a super
chat
super chat
um
i don't know what is up with the
lighting today i keep trying to fix it
but it's just weird i i don't know
it's a weird day in london it's a sunday
that's what it is i'd rather have a girl
with a flat behind than a bbl that's
what the comments say
that's their preference
i've heard that i want to say something
what i said what about natural
you just fly bvld two extremes what if i
really had just had enough yes i didn't
and
[Music]
in china celebrities are having so much
plastic surgery that their children
don't even look like them
yeah yeah that's another thing like if
you
if you get surgery and say someone is in
china i think they said
like say you
like your eyes a certain way and you
like your nose a certain way you like
your lips a certain way you want your
kids to have that like you have it and
so you want to
partner with someone who has those
features as well and you get in a
relationship with someone that has those
features and you end up having kids and
they come out the complete opposite
because you're like you have those
features and then you come to find out
oh this isn't my these aren't my natural
eyes or nose or lips and that's where
it's like you have to
let people know up front because
i know that's probably very specific but
no i don't like that really she had this
bad nose let me tell you it was it was a
honker
wow and her mom's was perfect really
nose job
and her mouth offered to get her nose
job too really
so was her mom's like hers like without
the nose job then is that why she had
yeah that's why because your mom had
those big ass nose but she had no job
wow that's so interesting
but there's like so many things out here
now for people to have like photos
botox like temporary like
plastic surgery or whatever i saw this
like makeup thing and this girl like she
stuck it up her nose and then she like
put it on her face and it was to flatten
her nose out
and
there's like those uh
those things that you see on the
internet that make your lips plumper is
it the filler it's not the filler it's
like the
actual lip gloss no it's not lip gloss
like a
a big like
lip and like you
put it around your lips and you suck in
it makes it plumper so there's just like
so much stuff out here to just enhance
whatever you have that you know
you never know what's real and what's
fake
[Music]
is that like getting a trim sorry you
know guys so like i want to compare the
girls guys okay okay
is that like a guy getting a trim like
is that not the same
okay
yeah like a haircut no i think a guy and
girl haircut would be pretty much the
same
yeah
because you know how like a haircut like
something i think it makes more of a
significant difference but that's not
that's not like an enhancement that's
not changing their
look per se like yes improving it yes
they look different when they ain't got
a haircut for two weeks and when they do
it it makes them look different but it's
not physically changing anything like
how your face shapes yeah i get that
yeah i do get that
have you guys this is a little off topic
have you seen the brittany runner video
where she tells girls that if they want
to catch a check to
f an athlete because none of them wear
condoms
do you know who brittany renner is
no shut up you don't know who bro
i'll show you her
that's a wild statement you've never
heard of brittany renner
also guys all super chats are going
towards equipment my lighting kind of
asked today you want to fix it send a
super chat
what if i was when i was typing on
google something really weird came up
would you pretend you didn't see it yeah
yeah i'm blind anyway if that has
happened to me so many times i'll be on
people's phones and i'll be like oh pull
this up and i'll be like
you ever go on a guy's phone and like
that hasn't happened to me yet and i
don't plan on it happening to me no no i
mean just like like googling and then
they googled something like
inappropriate no i haven't done that
before that has happened to me but i
wasn't trying to look for anything you
were just googling and then i was like
oh oh god that's the kind of you're into
this is brittany renner
oh okay okay okay yeah yeah yeah yes i
do what happened with her and pj
washington
so basically refresh my memory she dated
a bunch of athletes
and entertainers so she dated
oh my i should know his name the guy the
knee guy he got that cap kaepernick
colin kaepernick yes
until he got i butchered him no you're
good sorry
colin kaepernick yeah yeah
before then he got kicked out of the
league she's like next
really yeah yeah she and she dated um
actually let's go brittany runner dating
history
wow
uh i think she dated trey songz i don't
know who that is
she did she didn't chance the rapper
that i don't think that's a chance
what the
i don't know who that is
uh
uzi
oh he looks so different there without
the gem on his forehead i know that
makes a big difference
yeah so she had a video that i'd show it
to you but i i don't know how to set it
up so
you can all hear it but
basically saying
the cat like if you want to get a check
f and athletes send to them where
wow and it turns out that's like what
she did later really yeah and then she
gets she got a kid from
him yeah yeah and then she was mad
though because he was cheating and stuff
and that was i guess why she laughed but
do you think it's kind of like what did
you expect you did an nba player
but is that all she said to do anyway
yeah it's like what do you expect when
that's that's how you live in your life
and that's the advice you gave mm-hmm oh
five dollar super chat oh yeah thank you
how do you feel about
oh
oh that's a good question how do you
feel about a man who has a vasectomy and
chooses not to disclose it
that would now that's something that
would be need to be disclosed
on the first date like oh like do you
plan on having not maybe not the first
day but maybe like within the talking
phase like oh do you plan on having kids
like actually no i
i cut that off well you know vasectomies
are easily like
reversible
but if he's
if he's already made up in his mind that
he doesn't want to have kids
he ain't changing it yeah well well well
no some guys just get it so they don't
get a girl pregnant
because they don't want to like get the
wrong girl pregnant if a girl makes them
like i think i thought like a lot of
things like someone might not want like
marriage
but or like say they're like a cereal
cheetah they're actually
like a
they're just trash they don't just trash
yeah they're trash but then the right
that someone might make them want to
want it but i can see the devil's
advocate is like but if they really want
it they'd do it like they can only want
it for themselves
well i
if you're dating intentionally i think
like marriaging kids is something you
should talk about
but
yeah i would say only if you're dating
seriously yeah i don't think he needs to
disclose that unless it's going
somewhere
but if he said i want to be married and
have kids and he doesn't say that he had
a vasectomy i would be pissed yeah same
what about yeah i agree oh my god no and
they said it's easily like it's
reversible i forgot what it's like 90
something percent of the time but am i
okay
so i'm like we're gonna have to adopt
oh my god i'd be so mad do you think
it's the same thing if a girl's
infertile
yes yes yeah i think that is a
conversation
in the dating phase we like agree on
everything today hey
yeah this is like a
agreeable podcast today
yeah that's
because if you guys are both agreeing
like yeah we want kids and then you
don't tell him like
i'm infertile
then that's
that's
that's kind of like a slap across the
face like yeah i can't yeah i can't like
produce like actual kids we'll have to
adopt and
so it'd be something what do you wait
till like when you guys maybe get
engaged and she's like okay cool when
are we trying for kids or even before
that because not like even care about
marriage and then it's like oh i got a
vasectomy so
that is a huge stuff in the face like
you said no
i mean that's so disrespectful because
you guys
along the way would you not have
conversations about that like i agree
like even
around like your friends kids or maybe
like family members
like you kind of do you know what i mean
it's so it's so natural yeah no do you
guys do you guys date intentionally
like for marriage like do you guys have
conversations with the guys you're
talking to pretty early on like well
actually no first question do you guys
want to get married because i should i
shouldn't just assume
yes i do you do okay yes okay do you
guys like date for marriage now
essentially yes
um
like
all of the
all of the um like official
relationships that i have had
i've like
intentionally been like okay like maybe
this is the person that i'm gonna marry
yeah but obviously that didn't happen
but um
i do like in the back of my head i think
like is this someone that i could see
myself being with no matter if i'm like
talking to them or we're dating whatever
stage it is because essentially if i can
see that from the beginning
like as it progresses i should be able
to see more and more of that do you guys
when you go on dates with guys
because
i i really in my ideal world i'd like to
be married before
because right now i kind of want to stay
single for like six months ish okay
before i'd make anything like official
just because i got out of a relationship
in like
december and i tried to stay single for
like half the time like that was a year
yeah just to make sure like you're over
that yeah yeah yeah but when i start
like
dating like at this time around i'd like
to date more intentionally but it's kind
of hard because
i feel like if you tell a guy
right away like oh i want to be married
like they kind of look at you like
you're crazy
and so it's like i don't know it's kind
of hard because i do want to be married
you know i'd like to be married in like
the next two or three years if i can
yeah
but
i also think men are kind of more afraid
of marriage today
so it's just interesting to like
navigate like what what are your
thoughts on that i said a lot i know
you don't go abby
oh um
[Music]
i think yeah i think now i'm more i date
more intentionally like with the goal of
like it going somewhere i don't know i
do i wouldn't say oh i think of marriage
in the first instance but yeah like i
guess i do actually
i guess i do because it's like i'm
thinking of something long-term i don't
have like a high expectation
like because i feel like whatever
happens happens but it say they're not
on the same page it's like what's the
point why am i wasting my time yeah to
have
so i'm having a short time playing with
you yeah i'm gonna get my feelings
invested my emotional my spiritual life
everything invested just for it to end
like no like yeah yeah i will i would i
invest way more like
intentionally with dating what about you
you tell guys like up front i want to be
married in this time or is that like a
later conversation
i'm new to this dating thing how does
this work
um
there
are some times well it'll just like come
up in conversation we'll be talking
about like families and whatnot
and then i asked i go with some being
married something that like you want or
it's like oh okay like how many siblings
did you have and then just asking oh
like if you want kids how many kids do
you have so just coming up in
conversation and not just being like i
want to be married i would have kids you
can't do that i don't want to talk to
you like no not like that's hard though
because it's like okay no but here
here's the thing you also don't want to
like
like i see so many girls waste like
years with a guy who clearly doesn't
want to yeah marry them
you know what i mean like do you think
that's because they haven't had a
conversation about it
i think
i think it's um
like well i think i think it's more the
guy will
kind of make it seem like it's coming
and it just it just like a deception
yeah and so part of me thinks it'd be
easier if people were just like up front
yeah a guy that like wants to be married
in the next like two or three years like
that's not gonna freak out yeah you know
but then the other side of me i don't
know we'll see how i play it i don't
know we'll see what happens
make your move i'm kidding
[Music]
but i don't know
dating is just such an
interesting concept it's so bored i
don't think there's like any right way
or i think it's just people's preference
because i think
there's people that do date just to have
fun and there's people out there that do
like that so yeah they're for each other
whereas then there's the people that
have the intentions of long term and etc
like family sometimes even family but
not with the kids like
them too as a family yeah now i have a
question for y'all um would you
want to like if you had a choice would
you do how dating it is right now or
have someone like
set you up like a matchmaker type deal
oh set me up i'm done no i'm a swear to
god i tell my dad all the time that i
wish he could just
he wouldn't pick someone i think it's
cute i know he wouldn't
but
but no i i honestly
would prefer the matchmaker just and
just be done and trust my parents to do
it actually
because of the process
oh i'm just more traditional like i just
prefer traditional like i really wish i
could have met my husband in college
that's kind of what i hoped yeah
yeah it didn't work out for me
but that's what i was hoping would
happen um
but
i don't know and i think as women like
the things we're attracted to isn't
always what's best for us yeah
so if i had my dad do it for me i would
just trust him more than myself yeah
exactly they make the best decisions for
us yeah what do you guys what do you
think um
i think i'll choose now i you know i
quite like the whole dating world i
really enjoy it like there was a time i
even went on like two days from one day
i don't know how i did that
but it was like i had so much fun like
it was it was so good to just be out
there just being on dates getting to
know someone like there's not
necessarily any strings attached it's
like you're getting to know someone
there's no obligations
and it's just so nice that you have such
a good time like you might actually
connect with them like even on like a
friend level yeah or even like i don't
know i just feel like everything really
happens for a reason like you could
maybe work out for me in like
three months
maybe not now but it's just like i love
the whole face of like meeting people
getting to know each other like find out
what you like what you don't like
because i get to know myself more yeah
and i'm like oh i didn't know that yeah
i like it i i know what about you i
prefer now i
i don't trust
my
parents too
oh my god my parents no i would have
been sent off in an arranged marriage
my mother if my mother had to choose i
would be married by now with umpteen
children yeah i wouldn't even be the
cute guy what kids do you guys want
i want in a perfect world i would want
twins one boy one girl and then shutting
down the shop
i want twins too i don't think i don't
think i can get them like it doesn't
really run in my i have a cousin but
it's not really big in my family
but
i think i want four to six okay i want a
lot of kids okay but the problem you had
a lot of family i might run out of time
because it's like you kind of
i don't know i don't know i might go
like pro and if i do that yeah if i end
up with less it's fine
that's okay
i think i need to i can't have an only
child yeah i need two
and then whatever happens happens after
yeah
i think
i do you know i think so i'm thinking
about like even in a car like i actually
don't want a seven-seater car i'll think
about that then i was like
i want my kids to have like siblings so
i think in three
and then i was kind of thinking well
is that like two boys and a girl so
maybe like four then i was like okay i'm
gonna with the seven seater so i don't
know i think i think three i think three
minimum
but it just depends like how life works
out as well but
like i said i'll be happy with two
minutes actually i'll be happy with two
minimum yeah and then if i end up with
like four i'm i'm good i'm good with
that but i want twins as well like i
need the guy because twins ain't in my
family so i need the guy to have a
genetic twin team
you know this is gonna sound crazy
because so i told you the basketball
team
oh my god okay this is this is what i
want to do
and i know everyone's gonna look at me
like i'm crazy because this is so in a
perfect world okay if i could pick
i would have three sets of twins okay
back to back it'd be like drake like
back to back
three sisters
okay
and they'd all be like i would oh okay i
remember you telling me that
okay each so when they're in high school
it'll be like sophomores juniors seniors
i see this they're all boys
i'm tall
okay
clearly hopefully i'm trying to find a
giant right
so they're going to be giants so they're
going to be starting sick five and then
plus one on the basketball team yep and
the thing is i'm gonna make sure
that they know that how much i love them
is determined by how they play
[Music]
like the ball family this one literally
so so
it's also going to be a youtube house
okay yeah i'm going to be using my
children
for clout yeah like the
uh ace family yes yes like stop it
like the ace family i know all family
i was on my mom's facebook from a young
age
i was fine yeah exactly keep the bag in
the family keep the that
i'm gonna be like the kardashian
kardashian she's gonna be the one making
money off every opportunity that their
kid can get for sure manage the money so
then okay hear me out
i
i don't want my kids having bad coaches
uh-huh so what i'll do is after practice
i'll be like boys come on your coach
doesn't know what he's talking about
here's the play we're going to run
during the game tomorrow
and then if they they'll look at me
during the game i'll give them the
signal right
and then they're going to do the play
and then the coach will be like what
just happened but they scored uh-huh
and it'll be like
the kid that gets the most attention
from me that day a leading scorer and
i'm a defensive i appreciate that
if you get some blocks
but yeah so then i'm going to raise nba
players
and then therefore then i'm going to get
to go to nba games i don't really like
watching basketball so
just be in the box office just be there
for a good time i'm more of like a chit
chatter
there for a good time
yeah so what do you guys think do you
think that's a good plan yeah yeah i can
see you do you know what you should just
go ahead and apply for the coaching
position on their team
i want the freedom to not go to pr i
kind of want to go to their practices
that sounds like ass
have you guys ever watched dance moms
yes can you not see po i can see i can
see it oh my god that's how my family
was why do you think i do so much stuff
because achievement was very much
i mean it wasn't you know the same yeah
but but it was very much pedestalized
like the hard workers i always knew if i
wanted my dad to love me
he just had to work harder yeah that's
that's how that's why i work hard is
because i knew he'd like me better if i
did
that's d you were crazy
nobody was good for me okay it was
really good i got i did three sports in
college like i run a youtube show i
wouldn't be able to do all this yeah
you're doing great yeah so well
hopefully we'll see so i'm kind of broke
send me money
money super chats
[Music]
um to think if there's any other
questions i have about modern dating
we've gone over the talking stage
we've gone over
we don't really play games we need to
bring someone more toxic next time
i was kind of hoping you were a little
more toxic me yeah what happened in your
toxic relationship it takes two to tango
right it does i was in one too so we
could
i think
i don't think i i don't think i played
games i probably did some stuff that i
didn't like
because i think it's i think it's more
like me as a person i'm like a very like
socially adapted person like i can get
along with different people i'm very
introverted as well but i feel like i'll
know how to like adapt just like certain
people i'm around and i'm like a social
butterfly he didn't really like that
i think that's how my ex because it's
like he thinks i'm flirting with guys
and because guys
guys like to me and it's like but it's
not that because i think that's just i
think the security comes from like i
like a secure guy
i really don't like the jealousy stuff
like it actually like it puts me off so
bad i don't that's why i don't do the
games because i i don't want to know
you're jealous keep that to yourself
well sometimes it's it would be like i'm
just being nice
because i've just always i've just
always been i'm a chit-chatter
well of course you came here to chit
chats the first time i met you that was
like
but i don't know but he would always
just get so like jealous you know wow or
it'd be like
if i talked to someone too long i like
knew
he'd get like mad see like that stuff it
shouldn't like go into relationship
because you can't even like operate and
like be yourself because you always have
to
thinking like oh did i talk to this
person too long oh did i say something
that might upset him it's that's how it
was for me like i felt like i had to be
less
like myself mm-hmm because i've been
i've been chit-chatting somebody's like
the fifth grade
said i i'm
game to this
yeah
man
that's just tough uh do you guys have
any non-negotiables
they're like if this person did this
no no second chances no nothing we out
it's over i think it's lying um and
especially like the scenario as well
i think it's like if i've
yeah like you know sneaky things going
behind my back
like if you're talking to your uh
talking to your exes no like
you know i'm i'm actually on really i'm
great i'm on great terms with my ex like
one of my exes like we're so cool like
it's crazy and there's nothing there at
all but i think
say if but i'd be open up front about
that with my current partner whereas i
think if they was to like lie to me
about that or do stuff like sneak like
say like i see in your call log like
you're on the phone yeah like or you're
messaging it's like for me that's a no
because there's a reason you're hiding
you know what i mean i don't like that
yeah that's for me that's a no
like complete disrespect yeah that's a
no yeah what about you paul
um i mean i'm pretty conservative so
pretty if you're really like laughs i
don't care if you're like in the middle
yeah that's fine like my last boyfriend
wasn't really political but like if
you're super left i won't because i'm
just i just feel like
i'm super one like the clash wouldn't be
good you know what i mean yeah no i feel
you what about you
um
i don't know
i would say um
[Music]
as soon as you
like
is i wouldn't say it's not negotiable
but i always say as soon as you
switch up or like start showing that oh
what does switch up mean i hear this all
the time so
british what's the switch-up when when i
use it when i use the word switch up
it's like as soon as i see that you're
checking your energy yeah you're acting
different and that you're
you're not putting the same energy
towards it and it's not just like one
day and it's like oh you switched up
it's like consecutive
and
you're just acting completely different
that's when i know like okay i need to
step away i started moving different and
then i'm just like yeah
this needs to just
cut off
i think even like morals certain roles
will like if if i feel like you don't
have like certain roles like because you
know how i'll think of it it's like this
is what you're going to instill in my
children
so for me that's so important
like i didn't think that was like my own
family members i'm just thinking you're
getting cold like you're not actually
coming around my kids so if i feel like
you hold like you do certain things that
like i feel like you're going in so much
like for me that's a no and i won't put
like take that relationship further
if that makes sense yeah no i agree um
that's what's the point
i'm trying to think of any other
shorter than me like by a lot
oh yeah i can't
then i just wouldn't even go there yeah
i'm trying to think someone that i was
talking to um
lazy i don't like lazy
hmm
oh my god
wait elaborate i want to know about this
talk to us you know
[Music]
okay it was basically
my last boyfriend he he was very
successful on social media okay he had
enough money to afford a house but he
didn't have one because he lost his
like id socially he lost everything so i
helped him get it and then he got an
apartment but he couldn't get an id
because he didn't live anywhere because
he was homeless when he got famous on
social media does that make sense yeah i
mean is that like no birth certificate
or something you can use a birth
certificate like in illinois they need
to mail it somewhere and they need you
need proof that you live in illinois
yeah so it's kind of a car is not an
address unfortunately yeah so even if
it's like what if he stayed at our
friends could you not use theirs or is
that you actually that's the
the place
and then he
but yeah so
i did date a homeless guy technically if
we're gonna be like technical here
technically technicality yeah
a very wealthy homeless man like what
did what you said i was like
i'm asking but you said i was like very
like unless you drain in like that
situation or did that put did that turn
you off at any point as well actually i
don't know that no at first no because
it was more like i felt like i was
helping him
and you know i feel like as women we
like to be needed
so i enjoyed you know helping him figure
all that stuff out
it was just more
like other stuff in the relationship
that wasn't great but no i didn't mind
doing that at all
like i would do i would have done that
again even if we didn't date i probably
would help them
follow what question i like that you
said that yeah so as women we like to
feel needed
so you know how we talk about like we
have this standard yeah that we
like maybe like even a checklist
and do you think that's why we also
compromise so much like we kind of like
we kind of go for guys so below that
like say we reconfines a lot like we go
for guys like so blow that stand because
then you kind of feel like that guy kind
of needs you does that make sense
oh yeah
they call them
the they what do they say that the man
manosphere they call them like pookie
and ray rays which i don't really get
the reference no you wouldn't unless
you're in red pill okay it's like that's
what they call like bombs basically like
pookie and ray rays that's what they'll
refer to them as like when girls date
bombs
okay
interesting yeah i don't i don't even
know where
i've never met anyone named pookie or
ray ray
maybe in a movie i think literally i
don't know but i have but
no i've literally i've never met but
that's um
but they
i put it
i i don't know usually they're
attractive though but usually it's like
that the hot guy because they it's
really interesting they talk about like
women's mating strategies there's like
five guys and i just learned about this
the other day okay and so there's
they call him the guy in the the foam
cannon party
that's that's the guy that's just like
really attract like physically
attractive to him
then there's the guy that's um
legacy that's what i look for a lot
apparently
so legacy is
like you don't embarrass the family it's
like the
more true i don't know like when i say
oh i want a guy that's super hard
working and like yeah like that sort of
thing more traditional yeah that goes
more towards legacy which your legacy
could be different than say mine or
someone else yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah and then there's um
income which is
like beta need basically they call it
okay so girls look for guys that make a
lot of money or
um the other betas like parental
investment so that they think would
stick around for the kids okay
and i can't remember the fifth one and
i'm butchering these i know i'm
butchering them
did you find this online no it's like
it's uh gosh it's a whole this on the
red pill as well this is in red pill so
it's like a center of youtube and it's
really hard to explain and you have to
watch this
you'd have to watch rolo tomosi came up
with it okay and you have to watch a lot
and you're going to be offended at first
until you understand what they're
talking about okay gotcha
like for example they say that girls go
through epiphany phase between like 27
to like 30.
which basically means
they
it's just like the the clock starts
ticking faster and they're more in a
rush to get married mm-hmm and that's
around like 26 to 30 like it's different
for each girl yeah
and
i don't know like i've seen that you
know i've seen that for sure within like
friend groups and everything they'll say
girls hoe phase or whatever
between like 20 20 like 27 and below
it's a girl's whole face
yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's accurate
and she'll and but they they get really
extreme so they'll be like oh they'll
actually get ran through about everybody
so you kind of have to
filter it and just take it in in stride
does that make sense yeah because at
first i was like well i didn't do that
yeah
but but when you understand what they're
talking about like it kind of makes
sense
but
it's it's hard to explain
check it out
what do you think guys do you think
they'll hate it
most of
okay
well do you have any other questions
because i think i'm like pretty much
through mine that i had
how long would y'all be engaged for oh
that's a great question
um
i
would be engaged for a year a year okay
without a date
okay if i if i was if it was a year and
i had a date that's fine
okay
outside of unless there's like covet or
something yeah
so
you'd have to be married like sorry
engaged to a man that's
where it's just there's a year going by
and maybe like you're not talking about
a date or is it like
do you know what i mean i i think a year
i get very attached so i'm just knowing
myself i probably would
put up with that for you i'd probably be
irritated
yeah but
yeah like i probably
do a year and then if i didn't have a
date just
i like to think i'd leave but again i
get attached so hey
i like i like to think i'd leave
but
i don't know
how but i wouldn't really want to date
someone
for longer than maybe a year two years
today not getting engaged
okay yeah and i it would be different if
i was like 22 or 23. but
clocks are dead
yeah i'm 25.
yeah i wouldn't
it would probably year max for
engagement but it all depends on like
what
what would go what's going on i would
extend it if like something drastic
happened to where
i don't i don't know would like push
back our wedding i would extend it to
two years but like that's if something
extreme happens because i don't think
you should
be
engaged for
that long because what's the point i
agree it's just like literally playing
the yes planning a wedding is long you
got work all this good stuff but
plan the wedding get married and then
you're married it shouldn't be a long
drawn-out process yeah we were engaged
for five years would you be okay with a
courthouse wedding
yeah i'd be cool with that too i'd be
gucci with that do of course i i kid
with my family all the time like yo i'm
about to get hitched in vegas or i'm
about to just yep elope and then just
have a reception afterwards like
like i would be fine
just courthouse bring my
immediate family i don't know exactly
yeah i'm cheap too because they're so
excited
i want to be abroad on like a beach yeah
that's all i'll do i don't even care
about the extras destination weddings
are where it's at
and then honeymoon oh my god
that's it because it's like
you don't have to shift through
the people that you're like in the
middle of like
do i should i invite them or should i
not invite them it's just like hey i'm
inviting you if you want to pay for to
come you can come if you don't know
that's that's i never thought about that
because they have to really like you
yeah
to pay a lot of money to catch a flight
then
i think i would actually accommodate
them if i'm inviting you out for a
wedding no but then i also think it's
actually i'm not going to do your thing
it's also the definition when if they
want to come though yeah then it's also
like
but wait i have to pay for my wedding so
can we chill yeah like if you want to
come come but if you don't like don't
come what do you what do you think the
ideal age to get married is like perfect
if you if you could have had it as a
personal
i would have liked to get married
like now actually how do you again 25
okay like between 24 like
if i could have but i don't i don't
think that's gonna happen so it's fine
but
it's not like like i don't i thought i
was thinking 27 like you know like your
age like i was that i really needed to
change something i'm kidding
i really thought like that's for me in
like two years yeah i really thought i
could be married like into like but then
i also think like the amount of times
it's going to get to know person then i
think my career that's something i
really want to focus on yeah it's just
not going to happen i think i have to be
realistic so i'm like 30 that you won
yeah
when i was younger
i was like oh i'm going to get married
at 25. i have five years like four or
five years just with me and my husband
and then we'll start having kids
it didn't happen and so right now i'm
like there's
really not an ideal for me i'm just like
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
it doesn't because i've fixated on it
for so much of my life like
i i want to get married i want to get
married i'm like you know what if it
doesn't happen i'm
completely okay with that i think also
you know when you have like that i ideal
age it kind of changes how you make your
decisions yeah because you it's like you
know it's like even like with career
like
i want to be at in this position by this
age you kind of change your decision
like sometimes you make poor decisions
because of just that one goal you have
in your mind so it's that tunnel vision
yeah do you do you guys start see
marriage as a necessity
so we do we see
marriage is a necessity
no for
like just human beings in general or
for you or both of you because you need
2.5 million to retire by the time you're
65. wow so
the typically you need two incomes to
get that
so it's it's quite tough to do that
unless you're making a substantial
amount of money i'm i'm in a little
different of a situation just because of
like my family and stuff yeah but
um i was just curious if you've ever
thought about that
no i've never thought about um it from
like a financial standpoint because i've
always thought like oh i'm gonna have my
own and whatever i need yeah for me i'm
gonna be able to get it and i'm gonna be
able to live the life that i'm able to
have so i've never looked at it from
that standpoint it's so hard though
i know
you gotta have like a hundred jobs where
are you gonna get it
let me know i'll figure it out i figured
out
yeah um
but i do
want it to be a necessity but like like
i said if it's not if it doesn't happen
um
it doesn't happen i think it's it's kind
of hard because i feel like we were sold
this not even sold but growing up i
thought yeah yeah fancy yeah they sell
you
that these guys are going to like pursue
you heavily yeah and like it's just
and especially growing up like in the
church
like
yeah don't even get me started i think
the church kind of keeps girls single
because they they
they kind of
they kind of painted this picture yeah
this is how it's going to be this is
what you need to look for this is this
this is going to be equally yeah like if
it doesn't have this then give them time
of day
and it's just like he'll just pursue you
even though he has a million girls
chasing him yeah
and they just painted this picture like
this is how this if you follow these
rules this will happen this will happen
this will happen it's just like it's
just not how it works
no i know and that's the
and and you kind of just think like
you'll just naturally meet someone
like they did
before yeah my parents just like met in
college and when it doesn't happen
you're like what the why yeah and you
have to also think like how many people
were
physically in like
just on this earth
back then when they were there so their
towns were smaller more people so they
knew they knew of each other quicker and
they knew of each other longer so once
they met and started dating it wasn't a
long drawn-out process
yeah and now we have so many billions of
people in the world it's like
well and i think men are like more
afraid of marriage because a lot of them
saw their their parents their dad gets
screwed by the system or something or
child support all that stuff yeah
and i think
young men aren't really looking to get
married yeah and you're not really at
least i was never told to look at older
guys mm-hmm you know it's like frowned
upon if you look at older dudes really
yeah but i think it would happen is it
guys like
age aren't really looking for that the
these guys your
guys you want to you know date yeah
because i like older guys so i'm like
because i i've noticed every guy that
i've dated that was like 10 to 15 years
older than me
it's been a lot more intentional yeah
with dating yeah have you guys ever
dated a guy that's a lot older than you
yeah
how much
okay how
how what's the oldest guy you've dated
i'll go first
and then would you what's the oldest you
would go so
i the oldest guy i've dated is
39 and i
this was
like a 15-year age gap 15-year age year
14. okay no 14 because this was it
wasn't very long right it was just like
um a couple weeks but mm-hmm and i think
the oldest i would go
maybe 44
43 okay yeah i'd go like up to 20 maybe
okay i wouldn't care what about you guys
um the oldest have dated is i think he
was he's 28 mm-hmm
how old are you i think i was
it was like literally a short period um
so it's like five years
yeah it was a five-year-old i thought
you said it was five years you guys were
talking i was like
it's it feels like a bigger age gap yeah
but like i think we actually had like so
much in common like we really got along
like we're actually cool yeah um the
oldest had to go for some basically 25
i'd say
maybe
31
okay
i'm fascinated
what about you yeah um
i didn't date this person but
we
kicked it um for a minute we just kicked
it we kicked it for a minute that's all
you need to know we kicked it for a
minute
we went like we hung out we went and got
like food and then we like went to the
movies and so we just did activities
together
um
and i
yeah oh but you don't call that date
yeah no i just call it just hanging out
okay um
it was
let me think how old was i
it was like uh
he was
41 at the time when i was
26.
oh yeah i didn't i was not expecting
yeah
okay
they're fine it does not matter let me
tell you i have the biggest crush on
this guy that's on youtube he's like 44.
wow
sometimes they'd be looking fine
together and everything did you guys get
to the age okay where i
realized that old guys are hot because i
didn't even see them there's some nice
looking older men when i was 22 23 i
didn't even see guys that were 30. yeah
i was like they're
they're too old they're just old man
but then i hit 24.
and i started
looking twice
double takes are are old guys attractive
yeah how
yeah i would say yeah some some some no
i don't ever lower my standard just
because you're older but
some um
yes um
[Music]
there's just like how does he fight for
you can we talk about
who he won't see that i'm gonna say it
he won't see this
you i think you guys are i think you
guys are cool you know you guys find
this house oh you you already know no
wait can we not i don't want to say it
though
i'm on live don't say it can you all say
please
42 either 42 or 44. the angel numbers
anyways
he is so fine some people age really
good and i'm just saying that that man i
was saying man with chest is
would you would you date him hell yeah
he's got a woman so i stepped out he's
got he's got women he's got a woman
he has a girlfriend yeah yeah yeah he's
a partner
she's looking back to go for his
birthday
i know i know someone that hooked up
with him
[Music]
no i don't think so i don't think it was
recent but she it was really weird
because
i just met her
and the the girls on my on my team were
talking about
it was me i was talking about it
it was me
i was i was talking about how fun it was
it was me i confess it was hitting me no
i was the one chit-chatting about how
fine this man was
um
and then she it was i just met her and
she's like oh yeah i slept with him and
i was like
i was like i'm so jealous who are you
see that's that's something and this is
another topic that's something that
females do to like assert like to have
like a certain authority like oh yeah i
slept with him i'm like girl he didn't
wifey yeah exactly i wouldn't brag about
that
he's so fine maybe that's the actually
good he is
he's
beautiful like he's gonna age oh my god
he's gonna be like 50 yeah looking like
30 because you know when i first saw him
i thought he was maybe 35. i thought he
was around mine
i come back with that i was like hell
yeah then i found out he was 40
something and i was like okay that's
fine then i was like so i actually
extended my age like things for him boom
he's accepted
anything for him and then i found out i
had a woman and i was like is it a
serious woman yeah no this is his
partner yeah like that's what his
partner mean like this is like
i think they might be engaged actually
i'm engaged
okay that's his girlfriend so okay fine
fair enough he could he probably can't
step out i've had he does maybe in their
stuff
i'm not sure so it's not facts this is
all this is true okay guys in the court
of law this is all hearsay
can i can i disclaimer it's actually
hearsay it's here please
he knows he's fine as well like you
should know you're like looking like
that yeah yeah with a body like have you
seen this
chill chill
no he's so fine his womb is so lucky
good for her okay with a guy like that
okay that's so funny let's say he's rich
too i don't know he probably isn't
he's i think he's girl you gotta he's
getting like he's getting a promotion i
think so he's making more money i don't
say his job
okay but he's getting information into
it would you look the other way
if if he if it was just a
now and then type of thing
you you wouldn't used to leave no i'm
i'm not even gonna go there but you're
just good to look at
okay i don't know about you but those
type of guys scare me a little bit like
if you're too hot
i i kind of take myself out because i
don't think i could i don't think i
could keep you yeah yeah you're actually
like oh my goodness
you like me like why do you like me yeah
tell me you tell me why please show me
all the details like
what do you think what do you think when
you look at me oh my gosh there was this
this guy
yeah on on bumble like a while ago like
years ago okay
and he i
i ghosted him because i thought he was
too hot oh
i swear i was like what are you doing
talking to um
i'm not i'm not the most confident
person no i i feel you in that so i was
like what on earth you could have
anybody and um
yeah i found out later um
that he was actually because then
there's like mutual and then he was
trying to date me and he was mad because
i started dating my my boyfriend he's
like why'd she pick him i'm like i would
have picked you if i thought you were
serious oh wow
mommy's engaged fumbled the bag
that's what he told me he's like yo we
probably would have dated if you
wow
sorry that could have been a week ago
i was like are you you're sure about
that fiance you don't even mommy diet
come on are you sure you like her like
are you are you
oh my god i was like
damn
i was like you know what this is my sign
to be more confident in the future step
out
i definitely i think we actually get
insecure so i feel like you know even as
a woman oh yeah that's what i've
realized as like maybe like not a lot of
them but women like so like we have like
all these high standards and stuff but
like say it gets to the guy that does
deliver that we get so like nervous and
i'm actually there now but we get so
nervous
we get so like insecure just know she
saw me all nervous like you get so
nervous like you don't know how to act
like you'll be yourself but then you
can't because you're like oh like you
start overthinking things oh does it
happen to you no that's so true it's
true it's it's like so what is it with
us do we just like get away it's like we
have this guy that we want and then like
i find him and i'm like oh i don't
deserve that
are we like do you think we're like
thinking like too unrealistic like we
think it's like realistic but we're like
i should go below the belt then like
bottom barrel but is that i can't
because who i am i don't know
we know who we deserve
i could never settle like that but then
it's like
you'll get the guy in your life yeah
sometimes
i think maybe you're out of my league
but then i'm like no like maybe i should
i don't know
and then i fumble i think that all the
time i'm like why are you talking to me
yeah
i think that but i found out that guys
it's not really i actually did a survey
on my poll and i said the x or on my
channel because it's mostly men i said
did the x that you loved the was the ex
you loved the most the most attractive
and they all it was like 75 80 percent
said no really
yeah i think as girls we think it's all
about looks and it is
i think for men it's more like they have
a bottom feeling of attractiveness they
want and they're attracted to way more
than we are but if you get above that it
becomes more
like who you are yeah personality
but i think as girls a lot of times we
just assume it's all about looks yeah so
if i see you had a really hot x i think
why would you
yeah
dang have you do you guys have you guys
had like an ex that's like
the girls aren't we like he's
talked to or dated yeah they're not as
they're not that
good looking yes it's all about looks
but like how does that make you feel
like do you think do you think
i'm like that
or do you think oh i'm actually out of
your league because i do you know what i
mean yeah no i got you the two the two
dudes i had like serious things with
whatever both of them got married and
they're married now
and they i saw their
fiancees or girlfriends
wives now and i was like
you downgraded sorry about that but
it doesn't doesn't matter to me
yeah it's just like
hey
i didn't give you what you needed
hopefully you're happy yeah have fun
so yeah
yeah i didn't really care about a guy's
exes but i will stalk them so maybe i do
i i always thought like i'm actually the
best you're ever going to have that's
how i feel like sorry you're like so
like no other girls really you know what
i mean like yeah like so
you're i just okay this is how i think
okay
you're pretty right you're attractive
yeah but i'm like there's a million
people out there how could you be sure
you're the best he's gonna have like
there's a million but i feel like loki
have to think like that like no i have
to but it's like like you might not be
but i probably know the confidence like
i'm i need that excuse yeah i think i'm
too much of a real otherwise i'll be
i think i'll be too insecure like i'll
be like what is she giving you like
because i feel like i feel like there's
obviously a reason that you're you're
here
oh yeah yeah oh you're talking about the
guy you're dating now no like or an act
just inject yeah but also like a general
thing like there's clearly a reason
you're you're here oh for sure you'll
definitely upgrade like
i'm actually an upgrade because
sometimes even obviously there's
something like i'm an upgrade let's be
real yeah i don't know i always think
that
i always i'll never care about their
future like if they move on someone
better i'm actually mad happy for you
yeah like yeah i always tell my ex like
i'll be so happy for you yeah
like i want to find your wife
i'm not
no i think after a certain amount of
time i am but like right away now i feel
like there's a point where it kind of
hurts for a little bit but then you
start just kind of like letting it go
yeah yeah
because sometimes you don't give that
person what they need yeah and they go
get elsewhere and vice versa like you're
not giving me what i need like what i
want yeah and i'm gonna go get that and
you should go get that like why why
can't let's both be happy yeah
individually i wish more i wish more um
couples
would
understand that it's okay to be a part
but so many have been together for so
long that they're scared to start over
scared to
do something else because essentially
you're robbing that person of having a
happier life if you both don't think
like hey we're not good together but you
guys are just staying because of
comfortability and i also think long
term like in terms of kids as well it
just affects them so much like
so i'm gonna so say i just stay with you
because of comfortability yeah that's my
kids that's gonna be affected that's
just me gonna be affected then i can't
raise my kids right i'm teaching them
the wrong things like i think that's why
i compete on some polyamorous
relationships
like you go get what you want from you
know i'm from another obviously
providing
you get consent from the first of a
person yeah some people do it the other
way or whatever
whatever but people are in polymer
polyamorous relationships they don't
know about yeah exactly but i i respect
people that like i don't have anything
against it like i'll never judge it
because
it's like friendships like you get
different things from different people
different things are different like
we're all different it's just like you
know what i mean yeah it's how we are
okay this five dollar super chat thank
you brennan oh super chat
thank you
since arranged marriages are more stable
and last longer than marriages of
passion do you think looking for someone
mind-blowing is a waste of time
can you repeat that okay
so i guess statistically according to
this guy
arranged marriages are more stable and
long-lasting than marriages of passion
so where people like pick for themselves
do you think that looking for someone
mind-blowing is a waste of time
like someone that's like
amazing per like
do you think that's a waste of your time
no
no because you also have to think about
what is the percentage of people that
are getting in arranged marriages and
what
what is their
ideology of divorce like no matter what
like this is like you have to say in
this marriage it's like divorce is not
an option and i'm not saying that that's
all arranged marriages to where they
just
get married and they
can't it's more cultural i think yeah
and so
um
[Music]
there may be more arranged marriages
than um actual marriages happening so
maybe that's why the statistic is higher
because of the background of it but um
i don't know
i would say
i would say go for what you want and
not
just settle but what else could you call
an arranged marriage could you call love
is blind and arrange marriage because
you call
like these shows to where i think
arranged you need the family okay and
that's that's why i think it works
better because who knows you better than
your family yeah and who
like your family really knows you they
know what you like when you're an
[ __ ]
they know what you're not like when
you're not an [ __ ] yeah and they also
um
know what values
are important for your family but
could um
married at first sight be that as well
because they know they may not know you
know you as long term but they know like
the values and the things you like in a
person that's how they match you with
them
no no
reality
i know it's like different but this the
um
idea of
arranged marriage
i think with even like it's like
thinking of a cultural base like i come
from that like obviously more back in
the day not now it's not implemented but
i think with arrangement it's just so
difficult like
there's a like especially like we spoke
about like the divorce
thing
a lot of them
don't i wouldn't say i wouldn't call it
success because a lot of them don't
divorce because of cultural reasons
so they're just unhappy in relationships
that they feel obliged to stay in
because of how what their family will
say go on i think that's good
really
yeah i think that's good i think me
coming i think me
witnessing a lot of things is me like
i'm like no i could never do that i
really want my kids to go through that
because you should be happy and do what
you want a kid should not make you stay
in that's just in anything i i just i
know i disagree because i think i think
okay
we're going to take abuse off the table
i'm not talking about anything abusive
okay
or cereal cheating okay
but i think once you have kids it's not
about you
and kids are better when both parents
are in the house that is true so i think
that you should give up your happiness
for your kids i think that's what you're
supposed to because that's something
you've committed that's something you've
committed to and you're you're a mom
it's not about you you had your time in
the sun when you were growing up
hopefully you know
and you know my parents
you know have gone through like ups and
downs but
i think overall it's it's better if the
parents stay together so tell me why you
don't think so
i think your children can feel when
they're in an environment where it's not
like a happy marriage like
i grew up
not wanting marriage
for a lot of reasons that was one of the
reasons like
seeing like an arranged marriage
where there's not like a lot of love and
passion there's
your parents had an arrangement they had
an amazing moment and they didn't get
along
no
they did yeah they did they did but it
was they still married well my dad's not
here like oh anyways okay
but they did get along yeah and okay
cool it was good but i think there was a
lot of things where
say there wasn't like more of like a
love marriage yeah because that love is
kind of developed and created i think
and then there's also a lot of like
cultural religious
factors that come into it as
like why you kind of stay into that
marriage
like you said okay
yeah so then it's like
but then yeah i thought because it's
like as a person you should do what's
best for you
so it's like you could you could like
you could have left that marriage but
you didn't because that's that was your
culture you were arranged into that
marriage you didn't choose who you
wanted for you
and i think that's a big thing because
you're like forced into something you
didn't want i think we can say okay did
she not want your dad
it was a rain so i don't think at first
she was like no okay so she always said
yeah and then
that's all she knew yeah yeah
yeah they were raised back home for
example they got married here but they
were raised back home so you kind of
grow up on that so you don't know
anything else but i think maybe i'm
speaking it differently because i was
born here based here so i see things
differently but it's like there's a lot
of like a lot of things where if he
wasn't like a love marriage you wouldn't
tolerate you would feel more free to
leave that marriage and be like no
that's actually not for me like yeah
you're talking about kids i completely
understand that doing it like honestly
but how can you be good for your kids if
you're not doing better for yourself
yeah so
i just say i'm in like a relationship
i'm so unhappy i just think feelings
come and go
like what is consistent if it's that
consistent unhappiness for over like two
years
two years oh actually
i think
that if you want to be married like 40
years let's just say you have to go
through the rough times like you're
gonna have one or two years where you
don't like the guy you don't like the
girl like it just happens
and i i would rather see couples like
work on it you know and figure it out
like i don't i don't know what can't be
figured out outside of yeah outside of
syria i get that yeah on like
cereal lying you know con yeah like
outside of that stuff like
i think you can figure out
because i just i think i could love
anyone yeah if i spend enough time with
them yeah
like i don't know i think you can work
stuff out yeah some people go on you i
understand that it's funny because i had
a conversation with my auntie about that
yeah she was like because i was like if
the guy cheats on me i'm like i'm out
she's like no like she's like you guys
should talk about it work on it
and then i was like no she was like but
that's how relationships gonna work she
was like how are you going to keep a
marriage going on for so long and have a
long lasting hard-working marriage
if you don't like
work on it and go through the bad times
and actually get through that i was like
so you want to forgive my husband for
cheating i was like he actively made a
conscious decision to go cheat on me and
then he's going to like leave me
and then she was like
you have to talk about and forgive him
so i guess i understand that because you
have to like forgive and give a lot i
always say i wouldn't take back a
cheater
unless i had kids
really i would i would so kids is that
exception for you to allow it i just
don't i think it's it's not you okay
it's not about you and and i hope when i
have a kid i love them more than i love
myself yeah like because i i think
that's
growing up how my mom felt about us yeah
like she would
do anything like she carried seven of us
yeah
like and i i hope to love my kids that
much
i i hope i would pick someone that was a
good father yeah you know are you the
youngest by the way
are you the youngest um or i'm the out
of the original six i'm the second out
of the full ten i would be fourth okay
okay okay
because i told you guys a sick story
yeah yeah yeah
um how do you guys feel about women
passing on mr right because it's too
early for her
so it's um
a lot of a lot of in the space they talk
about how women have already met their
husbands and they left because they were
bored
or they just didn't feel like it was
right but that was like that was the
person they should have ended up with
but they left because they just thought
they were too young
or like not ready yeah yeah but now you
know they're say like 35 40 and they're
like actually yeah i should i should
have married that guy
have you heard have you one have you
ever heard a story like that or seen a
story like that i haven't like most
people i know are married
and two
what do you guys think of that
i'm trying to think of i've heard a
story
but
it's
it's like it's hard because
i feel like society says oh you're right
out of high school you're dating someone
from high school how do you really know
them how do you know that you guys are
supposed to be married and there's
people who i feel like if society didn't
like frown upon like people getting
married
like at the age that people got married
back in the day there would have been a
lot of marriages in college a lot of
couples like starting college
um
but i think that just like the thoughts
and like society and family it gets in
like people's head and they know like oh
i can see like at a young age spending
the rest of my life with this person i
would get married to them right now but
because of the standards that there is
it's like they go throughout that long
process so you think society discourages
young marriage
i think so
yeah i think so as the years have gotten
the years have grown um i do think that
it's like you can't you can't do this
you can't do that and how they're like
just making it just
expensive to be a human being period
it's like at that young age if you
didn't work from the time
you were
in
whatever grade on to graduation you're
not going to have any money to be able
to get married and start a family or do
whatever it is that you want to do
because of just how society is now
you know it's interesting you say that
because i think so too i think a lot of
girls leave a good thing because they
think they'll find something better yeah
and they leave like a genuinely good guy
because
i'm not like they'll see their single
friends going out and doing all the
stuff
and don't get me wrong
you know
like i went out a lot in college it was
fun
like i don't know i've seen girls leave
what could have been their husband yeah
i mean i'm young enough who knows if it
was or it wasn't we'll see how the cards
play yeah and then and that's another
thing it's like they would rather
choose something that is a temporary
which is going out and doing this at the
third for something that could be
like forever and longer for them in this
relationship with this person
and then all that other stuff will come
so
yeah it's
it's hard have you have you
broken up with
have you left mr right now are you one
of them no no
would you miss abby
not my college
yeah i think yeah no
yeah oh
does that make sense maybe yeah no like
yeah like in the sense of i think long
term like
probably a lot could have i would have
benefited yeah but i just think it's
just definitely not also like not the
right time and yeah i don't think if we
really thought about we're actually
right for each other just as individuals
so there's that aspect and yeah like no
so maybe no like i'm not i don't regret
it at all
but yeah i
i just thought of something it wasn't
someone that i dated but it was someone
that um
i'd went to school with and
we
we never talked we just like reconnected
later on in the years and we became
friends and we like hit it off and we
were just communicating we both like
there was just like that just tension
there
and um
i told him like yeah like i'm not like
looking to date right now blah blah blah
so we just stayed friends and then we
like
didn't talk and then we reconnected
again and like come to find out like
he's getting married and i'm like oh
that's great like congratulations and
then just he's like yeah if i want this
marriage to work i have to cut you off
i'm like
oh
all right and so did you ever like him
yeah yeah i did and i thought oh that
could have been yeah and i was like
i wonder and so i always thought about
like
well i wonder what if i would have just
been like you know let's try even though
i was on the other side of the country
and he was other side of the country so
that's what i've noticed every regret
i've had in dating because the guy the
guy in college um
i left but it was because he wasn't
taking me serio you know what i mean
like it was it was like i left but
really i was rejected you know he hit a
new girlfriend like two weeks later wow
yeah i was so sad because i was i was so
devastated i would have been devastated
like that's a slap in the face yeah
exactly it was a big yeah
i was very sad um because i was the guy
like lost my virginity too soon
because i was like older
but um
i don't know it
so i don't really count that you don't
even like i laughed yeah i didn't really
you kind of felt like you were supposed
to kind of yeah yeah it wasn't because i
wanted to
i've never but every regret i've had in
dating is like i wish i was i tried like
i was more forward with a guy when i
liked him and like actually like went
for it instead of thinking he was out of
my league or something yeah
i've had a couple stories
in my life like that where there was a
guy that i was into but i just thought
he was like too good looking or two
whatever and i didn't go for it and
that's if i had regrets like it's
usually that i didn't go for what i
actually had to check because i didn't
think i could get it
dang but you know you live when you
learn live and you learn guys i have a
question yes about this so someone told
me like a wise woman
told me that when you're dating you
should have
someone you're sleeping with
on like so basically like you know when
you're doing the whole dating thing like
with different guys
you should have someone like
like if you're going to sleep with
someone it shouldn't be the guys you're
dating it should be like someone else
except like besides that because it it
helps your mind like it because i feel
like sex kind of
blurs your
thought process so basically say like
i'm dating someone or they i'm in the
dating process but i've got maybe a guy
that i'm just sleeping with because then
it keeps the guy that i'm dating i can
think clearly i can make great decisions
who told you that
like my friend's mom okay my friend's
mom is she married
yeah okay okay okay she was like this is
just whilst you're getting to know
people like you're not in a serious
relation so oh so when you say that the
talking phase there
like have something because then you
won't give it up as easy as well and you
kind of you have like more of a
straightforward thing like what you
gotta think of that by the way isn't it
am i [ __ ] no
but if you're trying to get to know
trying to get to know someone yeah and
then you're
i i understand the concept because sex
can cloud up a whole lot when it comes
to
talking to somebody getting to know
somebody so i can understand that like
taking that out aspect out and like
having it elsewhere so you can focus on
one person but once it transitions into
talking
like so once you're actually like really
getting to know someone you're really
interested in them you stop obviously
okay that's why that guy is just there
for sex so you have no feelings or any
like attachment to them it's just that
women typically can do that i just yeah
girls have a hard time detecting i don't
think for a long time i think maybe for
like
a little bit yeah but not for a long
time yeah because your emotional
attachments are going to the guy you're
dating no no we're saying
can like you separate things from yeah
i think if you if you sleep with that
guy too long you're gonna fall in love
with that guy
and the second thing is
and that kind of [ __ ] i would be pissed
if i was a guy spending all this time
and money on a girl
just to find she's not sleeping with me
just to find out she's sleeping with
this other guy
and that kind of shitty yeah i mean to
the extent i like i would be mad to an
extent even me i would be mad if i was
dating a guy and he was doing that i'm
spending all this time and energy but
it's like not really serious like you
guys are just kind of in the getting to
know face like there's no like
conversation about exclusivity there's
no conversation about like
so you're just still getting to know
each other like you're still kind of
figuring things out and like
so up until that stage are they not
you're just going out on dates getting
to know each other
oftentimes they're really entitled to do
what they want like who am i to really
be mad if you're doing that
do you know what i mean i guess i mean
yeah maybe early stuff they have needs
but how okay so how long would you do
that for so you have the guy on the side
yeah how long like three dates five
dates ten days i think maybe probably
five because after five days i really
know if i really like you and i want to
pursue things like i really wanna really
get to know you and then by then i'm
like i think personally me i'd be like
do you know what i actually wanna give
all my energy to this guy
and maybe i might want to be intimate
with him i don't know it's almost like
that's out of like a fear mindset like
fear of getting attacked like i'd rather
be open to the new guy yeah i mean and
be able to put everything into that
mm-hmm and you like and if it doesn't
work out it doesn't work out yeah
i'll take the l yeah
if i have enough i don't know but i
understand i think a lot of girls do
that to be honest
guys do that yeah i think naturally
yeah
like i think
i think that's what part of that's
another part of red pill where people
get like pissed really yeah because
wait didn't i just realize no it's there
okay sorry i was wondering if that was
the webcam and that's why it's weird but
no it's not
the lighting is just so off today and i
don't know why
like you see how like it doesn't
normally do this but it's having trouble
it's like adjusting yeah like the whole
time
but
yeah i don't know
the
let's see if there's any other questions
in the chat okay
but do you guys have any more
modern dating is so different it really
is such a broad concept now like there's
so many different aspects to it yeah
compared to
nowadays it's like it's more evolved
it's like what's your rules personally
and you follow those rules and your
boundaries i agree like there's no set
rules yeah it's each individual like
that's what it's perspective too because
there's some people who just date just
to date
and people who just
don't even call it and they're just
going around hanging out with anybody
who want to get married people who can
stay together for
10 plus years and never ever get in the
trees do that no oh my gosh i could yeah
i would be so offended if someone just
wanted to date pretend like am i not
wifey yeah what am i doing wrong
no
they can't
that's an insult
especially if you've spoken about what i
want from the future mm-hmm
ten plus years i couldn't do it actually
that's my brother's
wife now dead it works out for some
people how long were they like ten years
dating i know some years and then going
someone who just got married uh
last month do you think those guys
are they settling for the girl do you
think or do you think
it's just more like they don't want to
do it till they have to or something i
know comfortability
that is you must be like because what
makes you not want to do unless it's
like maybe you have a visa like career
or yeah maybe you don't even want
marriage at that point like in general
but if you if that's something you want
from life and you're not marrying me and
we're dating over five years no way
yeah what am i doing am i not living up
to your requirements because then let's
just wake up and i can look did you see
like cassie and cassie was with p diddy
for how long
how many years yeah they didn't nothing
happened
um she's an artist
yeah she's a musical artist and then
she got she dated someone new after
their baker yeah they got in they they
had a baby in how long and gotten gay i
think they got engaged
that would kill me like it's like look
so yeah i don't know i can't do that
that long it's it's somewhat
i mean i've stayed i've stayed in you
know situations i shouldn't have been in
and i think it was a self-esteem thing
and i think i think if you're staying
that long and not requiring marriage
yeah if that's what if you want to be
married some people are like don't ever
ever want to be married but i think it's
a self-esteem thing do you agree
yeah i think so too
i think um that that may be a factor
um and then some people they have an
ideal style wedding that they want in
their head and they're not going to
proceed into nothing until they have the
money to have that wedding
but i don't 10 years i don't know i know
someone who just got married last month
um and they've been together for 10 plus
years and they are happily married and
have happy together
i will say i think older people don't
need it
yes because i think marriage is more for
building families mm-hmm so i'd
understand if you're over a certain age
and it's just like what's the point
yeah if you're over 45 and you're dating
what like why yeah i could see that
because it's it's like legally you're
you're
incurring a risk
for what like yeah you know
i would understand it but i think young
like younger i would be mad
yeah
unless i was like 15 and dated 12 25
that's probably acceptable
yeah
yeah that's probably like when you're
younger when you're like you're younger
in high school like middle school and
you [ __ ]
no school sweetheart and you stay
together for like 15 plus years then i
can understand that because yeah you're
not about to date for five years and
just be
20 and be like oh we're getting married
yeah
yeah
i agree
but okay to each its own i think that's
pretty much all my questions you guys
got any more
that's it for me
this was fun yeah
of course
yes thank you for having us i always say
they're my most consistent guests if
they say they're coming i know that
they're yes they show the hello
um you wanna tell them where they can
find you their links are in the
description but in case you're lazy i'll
have them read it
wave culture on instagram
w-a-b-e-c-x-l-t-u-r-e
um it's a girl just on ig it's dot ya
dot girl underscore jess and then on
youtube it's your girl just same thing
without the
dot and the underscores but an
apostrophe for the it's
and guys you should go subscribe to
jess's channel she's going to be doing
vlogs in the uk
and we're trying to get her to a
thousand subscribers but maybe a hundred
first yeah that's it let's say triple
digits very simple
so you guys should go subscribe also all
donations are right now all the money
that i'm getting is being reinvested
into the channel so equipment so i'm
gonna like fix whatever is going on with
this lighting today
so um send donations also
cooking with chris if you guys are
trying to lose weight
link is in the description i promise you
it is going to be the best most
sustainable meal plan you will ever buy
in your life like i've done a million
diets a million meal plans and this is
the only one that i could see myself
sticking to